hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in jean-paul sartre famous play no exit
here tick you lates a doctrine through
the mouth of one of the characters
towards the very end of the play that
hell is other people and this is a
catchphrase that has had a currency far
exceeding the the realm of sart's own
popularity in reading I think there's a
lot of people out there who've heard
this phrase and perhaps have used this
phrase without realizing where it comes
from and you might say well that's just
you know one-liner can that really be
representative of an entire philosophy
really it is a core doctrine for
jean-paul Sartre and we want to do is
think about why he says this and and
what does it really mean is it is it
saying something like while other people
tend to be annoying so it's nice to be
by yourself once in a while that's a
more superficial read you know we're
often tempted to say hell is other
people when other people are acting you
know stupid or obstructive or irritating
wait towards us or you know getting in
our way but sorry has something in mind
that that goes deeper than that that has
to do with the human condition and I
think it's helpful from the very
beginning to think about this in terms
of the human condition
very often when we
about the human condition we think about
or human nature we think about the
individual person what is it to be a
person and for Sartre you could say that
on the one hand there is this
thoroughgoing individualism but there's
a thoroughgoing individualism precisely
because the flip side of the coin is no
human being exists on his own part of
the very nature of human consciousness
is to be conscious of others and be
conscious of oneself through the effects
that others have on us as other human
beings force art this this leads to a
sort of tragic condition tragic in the
sense that it's impossible for our
desires to be realized it's impossible
for us to be happy it's even impossible
for us just to be content if we're you
know if we actually do feel content it's
because we're concealing from ourselves
the fact that we're actually on a deep
ontological level not contempt not happy
and hiding from ourselves the reasons
why that's the case
so that's said let's actually think
about this in terms of the play itself
this particular work of literature and
then we'll look at it in terms of sart's
other works very quickly because there's
a core concept video and tie it in with
some other themes that I think helped to
flush it out so in this play no exit
Sartre has these three characters four
if you count the valet who is actually a
servant or a devil or something like
that and they're in Hell howl as they as
they very quickly realize is not a place
of physical torture the way that it's
been portrayed in so many cases there's
no no burning coals there's no flames
there's no torture devices instead
they're placed in a room that's
decorated and rather poor taste
according to their own sensibilities so
already you can see kind of the
hellishness there and nothing can
actually be really changed or moved
and you can't get out and slowly they
start filling the room with the three
main characters who are going to be
there first there's Garcia who is a
newspaper man who fled Rio where he had
been he was supposed to not be
conscripted and fighting a war and he
was a pacifist so he tries to flee to
Mexico gets caught and then gets shot by
a firing squad so he's dead
and then there's in as and as is a kind
of in her own words kind of a nasty
woman you know who doesn't really have a
lot of nice things to say
she's also and you know you got to put
this sort of in the context of its times
because this would be quite scandalous
that she's a lesbian and then there's
the third character and how would you
describe her sort of a social climber
type came from from you know rags to
riches by marrying somebody two or three
times her own age falls in love with
with it you know people who sort of
worship or talk nice or you know pursue
or court her who are more her speed and
is rather superficial in many respects I
suppose I should add in DES is coming
from a lower strata of society in that
she's a post office clerk she's part of
bureaucracy
whereas this other this other woman
Estelle has managed to so we're going to
make her way to the top high society so
you've got these three characters
they're stuck with each other and I'm
not going to try to talk about all the
ins and outs of their discussions I want
to focus on what's most essential why
Sartre would have them say hell is other
people
in nez realizes about you know halfway
through the play I would say that they
are not going to run into any torturers
no Devils or anything like
that they're actually placed there to
torment each other and as soon as
Garcelle fight you know here's that he
says well you know we can keep ourselves
from doing that actually he suggests
from the very beginning we're going to
be stuck here for a long time together
let's try to be as polite to each other
as we possibly can
why can't these people be happy together
why can't they come to some sort of
modus operandi well as it turns out each
of them desires each of them wants from
the others things that they can't have
and as for example is attracted to
Estelle Estelle is repulsed by and nez
except you know when des does things
like like act like a there's odds mirror
for her
Garson says that he merely wants to be
left alone he can't get that you know of
course because these two women are there
Estelle desires him and you know sort of
puts the moves out on him but basically
because she wants the the being
attracted on his part to her
and that feeling vitality that can come
with with with lovemaking and not just
in the sex of you know not just in the
sense of the sexual act but all the
other things that that's around and then
lead up to it
Garson I actually want something from
both of these women he wants a kind of
validation from them and as it turns out
that's really what each of them want
from the other some kind of validation
and that is perhaps less overtly than
than the other two they can all relate
to each other they all get to know each
other and get to know sides of each
other and they're all unable to see the
other person also to see themselves as
anything other than despicable for the
qualities that they have the kind of
person that they've become the acts that
they've engaged in it's sort of like
that expression that
something can't be unset or a bell can't
be unrung as the play proceeds you have
revelations of garson's cowardice of
Inez's essentially sadism you know or or
just meanness of Estelle's sort of
duplicity and neediness on her own part
the fact that they're all you know
willing to do things that they know are
are wrong and that they they hold
themselves up except for perhaps and
adds to higher ideals and just fail in
them altogether and they fail in in
different ways but they all fail they
all want something from the others that
the others can't provide them with or
won't provide them with and we'll get to
the why in just a moment they can't
escape from the others either garcetti
actually tries to go he says I you know
I can stand this because I can spend a
time just you know considering my life
and putting things in order but he can't
physically get away from you these two
women Estelle when she's trying to
seduce Garson basically to tickle off in
Eze she can't get Garson to not you know
be stuck in the presence of Annette's
andin as is both at the same time sort
of egging them on and saying yeah go
ahead and do it to have sex in front of
me and at the same time horrified by the
fact that this might happen
physically repulsed and nothing can
really work nothing can really work and
they can't get away from each other
that's the hellishness of this situation
now we should ask ourselves what it
would it started actually doing with
this plays it's supposed to be a
metaphor for the human condition as such
because we can in fact walk away from
each other and choose who we associate
with so is this supposed to be an you
know what happens to bad people to
people who don't fit sart's sort of you
know
ethic what there is a bit in his works
well you know in a certain viewpoint
we're all pretty much hypocrites we all
end up in bad faith at one time or
another so perhaps we all end up in hell
these are sort of open questions now is
where we want to contextualize this in
terms of ideas that are coming to us
from sorts other works in particular his
philosophical works and I only put a few
things up here there's other ideas that
I think are quite relevant to this you
know for example the notion that we are
we we choose to be now that doesn't mean
that we have like sort of an unlimited
wave your magic wand and suddenly you're
the hero sort of thing like it you know
like it nez points out to get set in
this you dream of yourself as the hero
because the hero is somebody who's
always on the right side but really
you're a coward and you you conceal from
yourself the fact that you're not a hero
at all as a matter of fact you're just a
guy who chooses to do bad things like
for example cheat on his wife in pretty
dramatic ways that he talks about um so
there is this element of choice but
choice that doesn't get us out of this
fundamental tragic predicament that's
art things that we're in but it's based
on something a bit different something
that's that's also I would say in some
respects a bit deeper and it has to do
with our consciousness of other people
what we call the consciousness of Altera
T in philosophical language force art
this is something you can say pretty
much running through all of his works
the other the other human being is
experienced as an alien freedom as being
free which means that they can pursue
things quite different than I want them
to because they want that because they
willed it and they are equally where
humanity is it's not like I have
humanity locked up in myself and then
other person over there is human or
inhuman depending on whether they
conform to my ideals I'm actually
subject to their ideals just as much as
they are to mine they're the product of
their choices just as much as I am and I
can't count on that other person to see
things in the way that I do to desire
the way that I do to see me in the way
that I would like them to see me or the
way I would like to see myself so I'm
vulnerable to them they are a kind of
threat to our own meeting or desire the
way in which we we view things you know
here's a trivial example I can make a
joke because I think I'm a funny guy and
the other person can confide it funny
and then perhaps trump me by making a
better joke and then you know I'm
feeling sort of unsatisfied or they
don't get the joke or they they condemn
my joke they disapprove of it or there's
all sorts of other possibilities
they twist it in an ironic fashion and
so there's always this this contest of
not just wills but on a deeper level a
contest of desires and meaning between
myself and the other person the other
person is sort of like a sinkhole in
being over there sucking everything to
themselves he says at one point in being
in nothingness
so if you have this point of view it's
not too hard to arrive at what's going
on in knowing that namely the hell is
other people that is that other people
constitute a fundamental barrier by
being like us to our own satisfaction
our own happiness our own being able to
feel secure to say that thing's
definitely matter this meets its kind of
Crocs in in sart's discussion of love
and his construe love love is the desire
for the others desire of myself when I
love another person
what I'm actually doing according to
Sartre is wanting to make them into some
sort of object which at the same time is
able to be a subject and to you know
want me to desire me to see me as good
to see me as valuable so I can sort of
count on them eternally forever I can
feel safe with them and their evaluation
of me and there's a lot of what we would
call in philosophy antinomies involved
in that the other four Sartre the other
can't be an object you know that I can
rely upon and yet be a subject that has
freedom at the same time so I'm screwed
basically I want from the other what
they can never truly give me and at the
same time the other wants from me and
demands from me and imposes their
structures of desires and expectations
on me what I cannot actually supply them
even if I say that I will even if I say
that that I can and I do it for a
certain amount of time in sart's world
we never fully persevere in these
because there's always a chance that I
could like go off the path and as a
matter of fact for Sartre if I am giving
in to somebody else's desires for me to
be a certain way to be a certain kind of
person I'm actually living an
inauthentic life so it's one of these
sort of things where you know to use
I'll make a pun your pardon my french
where you're screwed no matter what you
know you can't get satisfaction by
actually doing what it is that the other
wants you can't get it by revolting
against the other for very long you
can't get it from the other and and what
you want from them what it is it you
want them to think about you or feel
about you in fat and you can't get away
from the other you can change your
particular you know pieces around you
just like you can move pieces on a
chessboard so you don't have this
one right here you can move that one
over there and put a different one in
place say the queen or a rook but you're
always going to have somebody because
that's the very nature of human
consciousness to be involved with other
human consciousnesses and to be unhappy
with them to be stuck in this tragic
essentially contestation of wills so
that we can say that hell is in fact
other people and that we are living out
something like that hell here on earth
day to day not in quite so dramatic form
as no exit has where you you know it's
very clear you can't get out of there
but in something very like that Sartre
is saying that this is really the human
condition